gente grande parte das pessoas a maioria
das pessoas elas sempre querem fazer o
seu melhor né
em relação aos nossos filhos já desde
pequenos a gente ensina a eles a fazer o
melhor que eles podem das escolas e dos
professores a gente também espera a
mesma coisa que eles nutram em nossos
filhos
essa condição de poder fazer o melhor
nas organizações isso também não é
diferente
os gestores e líderes esperam de seus
colaboradores sempre que eles tenham a
melhor performance
o melhor desempenho e aí a gente segue
pela vida assim querendo sempre fazer de
melhor
e aqui nesse evento de hoje toda essa
equipe do ibmec né quer fazer o quê pra
vocês
o seu melhor eu também da mesma forma
estou aqui tentando neste dia contribuir
com vocês fazendo o que eu tenho de
melhor e com certeza todos os
palestrantes que aqui estão presentes e
assim também como vocês que saíram de
casa no meio como victor falou estão
aqui para viver o melhor desse dia
mas será que realmente quando a gente
chega ao final da nossa trajetória
diária que a gente chega em casa ea
gente olha o que a gente realizou será
que realmente chegamos no ponto em que
gostariam os será que realmente
conseguimos fazer o nosso melhor naquele
dia e aí a gente acaba realmente se
questionando será que a gente tem
condição de identificar o que realmente
pode ser a nossa melhor versão será que
a gente identifica em nossas vidas
quais são as nossas qualidades humanas
positivas sobre as quais podemos lançar
mão
o para fazermos o nosso melhor
identificamos realmente como constituir
a nossa melhor versão enfim hoje é que
junto com vocês eu vou tentar passar a
ideia da vivência que tive até hoje
tanto na minha área profissional como na
minha própria vida a respeito de como
realizar a nossa melhor versão com alto
conhecimento positivo essa idéia que eu
quero deixar vocês no dia de hoje bem
como ser humanos com indivíduos não
importa em que sociedade estejamos nós
acabamos sempre tentando olhar para o
que não vai bem conosco
a gente sempre tenta é corrigir algum
defeito é perceber algo que nos falta e
assim nós construímos o nosso dia a dia
buscando saneamento efetivamente do que
não temos até mesmo quando olhamos no
espelho a gente acaba sempre procurando
algo o que devo a corrigir o que a gente
deva fazer essa é quase que um hábito
ancestral que a gente tem e meio até que
diz sobrevivência em relação à nossa
espécie de ser humano então a gente
caminha pela vida observando isso com os
nossos filhos o que a gente acaba sempre
fazendo a gente acaba sendo sempre
buscando corrigir neles alguma atitude
não aceitável socialmente e às vezes a
gente não vê naquele tipo de
comportamento talvez até uma qualidade
humana e um talento que esteja obtido na
mesma forma a gente acaba quando os
nossos filhos na escola através dos seus
professores não têm a nota desejada né
ou seja a gente se prende naquela nota
baixa naquela nota boa que não foi
tirada no lugar às vezes de
potencializar o mérito o ganho no que
ele é melhor e aí seguimos né pela vida
e dentro das organizações no contexto
do trabalho e isso também acaba não
sendo diferente porque nas organizações
o foco em especial do desenvolvimento
humano e profissional está centrado no
treinamento das habilidades que não
temos dos gaps de competências que
precisam ser sanados naquilo que querem
que sejamos hoje melhores e não sabem
nem se a gente tem habilidade ou talento
pequeno que seja para que assim a gente
seja bom naquilo e aí além disso também
dentro da do relacionamento com as
pessoas no relacionamento amoroso a
gente acaba às vezes buscando a outra
metade como se não fossemos integrais
como se não fosse como se não nos
bastasse mos em termos de tudo que temos
de bom na verdade então isso faz parte
do nosso dia a dia do nosso cotidiano e
além disso né nesse nesse século 21 onde
cada vez mais nós temos inúmeras
alternativas e oportunidades de vida
acabamos construindo um cotidiano de
multitarefas fazemos milhões de coisas
ao mesmo tempo e inserimos uma
quantidade imensa de atividades no nosso
dia-a-dia preenchemos todo o nosso tempo
às vezes com coisas que nem escolhemos
por nossa conta às vezes somos
impulsionados por uma onda efetivamente
de estão todos fazendo é assim que
precisa ser feito e acabamos não
escolhendo aquilo que nos nutre o em
termos de bem-estar
em termos de felicidade acabamos sendo
levados por essa onda e não captamos
realmente escolhemos no nosso dia a dia
tudo aquilo que pode elevar a nossa
felicidade
e aí surge dentro dessa minha história
de trabalho da construção dessa ideia
que eu trago para vocês um estudo sobre
a felicidade e as qualidades humanas 1
estudo científico surgido em 1998 é
elaborado e divulgado através de martins
é lima o estudo da psicologia positiva e
nesse estudo né com pesquisas com
critérios rigorosos científicos chega se
hoje a um manancial de conhecimento
sobre nós seres humanos com relação aos
aspectos mais positivos que temos em
nossas vidas seja em relação às
qualidades humanas ou seja ao que
escolhemos para impulsionar a nossa
felicidade e com base nesse nesse estudo
da psicologia positiva é construa o
autoconhecimento positivo que venham
aplicando dentro do contexto
organizacional nos trabalhos de kohat
com os familiares na minha vida e é isso
que a gente vai tratar agora primeiro
momento de se auto conhecimento positivo
que a gente precisa e identificação de
nossas qualidades humanas
atualmente através desse tudo estudo
científico nós temos condição de lançar
mão de aceh simas ou avaliações que
identificam com extrema precisão o que
são as nossas qualidades humanas
positivas e nesse sentido através desse
acesso mas você com você consegue se
reconhecer de uma forma mais verdadeira
de uma forma mais real
você acaba acessando os talentos
as forças de caráter os pontos fortes
que você tem dentro de você e que você
não imagina e nem sabe se tem
significado ou não eu vou convidar a
todos que fiquem de pé por gentileza
vamos lá de pé
gostaria de pedir a vocês que vocês
fechassem os olhos e pensassem nesse
exato momento em um momento em uma
atividade de vocês em que vocês foram
muito bem em algo que você efetivamente
tiveram muito sucesso e esse sucesso
veio carregado com uma experiência de
bem estar e de felicidade muito
significativa muito forte na vida de
vocês pensem nesse momento o que
sentiram como vocês se comportaram
lembrem se dos resultados que vocês
tiveram exatamente vivenciando essa
experiência sintam a felicidade que
acabou surgindo em função desse melhor
desempenho que vocês tiveram podem abrir
os olhos por favor
vou dar a vocês agora dez segundos para
que vocês identifiquem três qualidades
humanas de vocês e que vocês utilizaram
neste momento vamos lá dez segundos 10 9
8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
saíram nas qualidades humanas
então por gentileza começando dia
apresenta esse é quem está próximo de
vocês dêem o seu nome e é fale sobre as
três qualidades humanas que vocês
identificaram alguns segundos pra vocês
vamos lá
apagou ele apaga
alguém me avisou do tempo
de semana
vamos lá gente foi fácil foi agradável
muito bom falar de qualidades humanas
então você já começaram a entender em
que nós precisamos focar realmente para
descer e reconhecer o autoconhecimento
positivo só que é o seguinte gente não
adianta nada minha gente realmente você
só identificarem seja através de um
acesso à credibilizado pela ciência ou
seja através de uma percepção subjetiva
de vocês quais são as suas qualidades
humanas
isso não basta é preciso colocar em uso
é preciso a gente potencializar essas
qualidades humanas porque as pesquisas
já comprovam que a medida em que você
utiliza essas qualidades humanas você
cria benefícios não apenas para vocês
mas também para todas as pessoas que
estão ao seu redor
ué você quando identifica e usa suas
qualidades humanas você acaba percebendo
no outro também o que ele tem de melhor
você se torna um ser humano capaz de
observar o olhar do outro enxergar no
outro e suas próprias qualidades e aí
vocês falou assim ah então tudo é um mar
de rosas
a gente não tem mais defeitos a gente
não tem mais nada a corrigir
não se trata disse vou tentar
exemplificar pra vocês de alguma maneira
à medida em que a gente na vida acaba
sempre focando apenas nos nossos
defeitos nos nossos gaps de competência
no que nós não temos você foca sua vida
toda apenas para uma parte do que você
vivencia no seu cotidiano identificar e
usar as qualidades humanas nada mais é
que voltar esse olhar para o lado
positivo dos aspectos que vocês têm que
vão fazer com que vocês progridam com
mais sucesso em tudo que vocês fazem
logicamente que esse lado de cá ele não
deixou de existir
ele continua ali porque a nossa vida ela
é cometida por adversidades e por
situações que nós precisamos vivenciar e
encararem
essa vida mas à medida em que você
consegue captar essas qualidades humanas
você inclusive consegue melhorar essas
deficiências que nós temos e os nossos
defeitos os nossos gaps de competência
então aqui não se trata de achar que
vamos viver no país das maravilhas e que
nada de ruim vai nos acontecer o que nós
vamos parar de ter a necessidade de
corrigir os nossos defeitos é muito
diferente disso um outro ponto
relacionado ao autoconhecimento é
identificação do que nos faz felizes
está comprovado que um bem estar mais
elevado uma felicidade na o tecida ela
favorece o ser humano em inúmeros
benefícios em nossas vidas
aumenta a nossa perspectiva a nossa
cognição a nossa condição de
criatividade
a nossa solução de problemas da nossa
saúde a nossa longevidade enfim são
inúmeros benefícios que a felicidade
traz em nossas vidas
então o que a gente precisa identificar
em nossas vidas o que nos faz felizes e
atualmente no estudo da psicologia
positiva temos já estudos feitos sobre
alguns elementos que possibilitam isso
com as emoções positivas dos prazeres e
as gratificações como os relacionamentos
positivos e significativos que vivemos
nossas vidas como as nossas realizações
cotidianas como significado e propósito
que vivemos no nosso dia a dia quando
praticamos algo com o propósito de algo
maiores nossas vidas e além disso também
aquelas experiências que vivenciamos no
nosso cotidiano que fazem a gente perder
a noção no tempo que no caso chamamos de
engajamento o flu então logicamente que
não basta identificarmos só isso é
preciso que a gente coloque em prática
tudo aquilo que nos faz felizes e aí
nesse sentido é que vamos usufruir de
todos os benefícios que a felicidade nos
traz
e como os estudos
georgios de harvard já afirmaram o que
vem antes em nossa vida é a felicidade e
não o sucesso
houve uma inversão do universo do
trabalho onde isso foi verificado
através de pesquisas credibilizada e
nesse sentido o que acontece com todos
nós né
nós não vivemos sozinhos nós vivemos em
sociedade e à medida em que nós
conseguirmos através dessa minha ideia
que passa a vocês hoje através do que é
o conhecimento positivo nós podemos
despertar e despertar para uma sociedade
melhor
uma sociedade que viva com mais
significado
lançando mão efetivamente de tudo que
tem de melhor no seu potencial humano
essa é a minha ideia pra vocês neste
momento
[Aplausos]